[Music]
everybody for Mother's Day you getting
ready I did you you got to take care of
that people gearing up for Mother's Day
you got to get the presents you got to
show up with something you got to get
mom something here's the problem though
with the economy in rough shape many
people have to stick to a tight budget
when buying Mother's Day gifts this year
so here with some money saving Mother's
Day tips is once again our prop master
bill tall bill take some broccoli dip it
in some pepto-bismol boom Mother's Day
flowers
hey Bill here's bill with another tip
apparently take a bottle of 409 write a
French word on it boom Mother's Day
perfume
I guess there's another one take a steam
cleaner grab your mom boom
day at the spa and here's another one
take a wallet out of your co-workers
jacket steal the money boom
happy Mother's Day
[Music]
[Applause]
Mother's Day here's another one think
about your mom and all the emotional
pain she's giving you over the years
drink a bottle of booze to forget about
it
[Music]
that was some incredible acting from
bill top right